KNOW, I'M JUST --
MIKE AND DAVID, THANK YOU BOTH.
JOINING ME NOW, FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE MIKE POMPEO AT THE
HUDSON INSTITUTE, MR. SECRETARY,
GREAT TO SEE YOU AND I WANT TO
JUMP RIGHT IN.
DEMOCRATS ARE SO WORRIED ARE
THEY NOT ABOUT PROTECTING
DEMOCRACY AROUND THE WORLD AND
WE ALL ARE, BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, APPARENTLY THE
GOVERNMENT WILL JUST USE EVERY
BIT OF POWER AT ITS DISPOSAL TO
TARGET ONE MAN WHO IS A LIKELY
2024 PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES,
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT
YOU ARE HEARING TONIGHT?
>> LAURA, YOU HAVE IT EXACTLY
RIGHT, THERE ARE NO RULES.
IT'S JUST ABOUT POWER.
AND THEY HAVE TO GIVE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT TALKING
ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW, BUT WE
HAVE SEEN IT.
WE HAVE SEEN MY PREDECESSOR AT
THE CIA POLITICIZE AND WEAPONIZE
THE CIA, WE SAW JIM COMEY WHO
WAS A COUNTERPART FBI WITHOUT
THE CIA DIRECTOR GIVE AWAY THE
FUNDS AND TAKE NOTES AND LEAK
THEM TO THE PRESS.
WE HAVE WATCHED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT UNDER MERRICK GARLAND
GO AFTER HER PARENTS TERRORISTS
WHO ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR KIDS GET TO SCHOOL, NO
REASON TO GIVE THEM THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT.
AND HAS NOT BEEN OFFICIAL, WHAT
THEY DID RUNS SQUARE AGAINST THE
CENTRAL PIECES WHICH IS ABOUT
TRANSPARENT EQUAL APPLICATION OF
THE LAW ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU DO
IT AGAIN SOMEONE WHO WAS YOUR
FORMER AND COULD POTENTIALLY BE
AGAIN YOUR POLITICAL OPPONENT.
WE DON'T SEE THIS IN AMERICA,
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD GO LIGHTLY AND IT IS
BIGGER THAN WHAT JUST HAPPENED
LAST WEEK.
>> Laura: MR. SECRETARY, WE
HAD HILLARY CLINTON'S PEOPLE
DESTROYING THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF EMAILS.
THIS IS WHEN DONORS TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION WERE TRYING
TO GET INTO TALK TO
MRS. CLINTON.
YOU WERE SECRETARY OF STATE.
IMAGINE IF YOU HAD DONE ANYTHING
APPROACHING WHAT WAS GOING ON
WHEN SHE WAS SECRETARY OF STATE.
I WOULD NOT EVEN BE TALKING TO
YOU RIGHT NOW.
THEY WERE PROBABLY PUT YOU IN
RIKERS ISLAND.
IT IS CRAZY.
SO THAT'S WHY THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD HERE.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVE DID NOT
HAVE ANY PROBLEM WITH THAT,
APPARENTLY.
>> DON'T FORGET THAT I WAS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THAT, WITH
TREY GOWDY.
WE WERE WORKING TO TRY TO GET
ACCESS TO HER EMAILS AND HER
SERVER, WHICH EVERYONE ADMITS
HAS HIGH-LEVEL CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND DID NOT WRITE
HER HOME OR SEND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND TRY TO WORK
THROUGH THE PROBLEMS IN THE
TRADITION OF AMERICA AND
VIOLATED THE BASIC AS YOUR POINT
IS WELL TAKEN, HAD MY WIFE GIVEN
SPEECHES FOR $500,000 ALL ACROSS
THE WORLD TO FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS
WHILE I WAS CURRENT SECRETARY OF
STATE I WOULD HAVE AN ORANGE
JUMPSUIT AND A PRISON NUMBER.
>> Laura: LOOKING AT YOU AND
YOUR COLORS TONIGHT, ORANGE IS
NOT YOUR COLOR, MIKE.
MORE OF A DARKER HUGE PERSON.
I KNOW YOU ARE INTERVIEWED BY
THE JANUARY 6TH COMMISSION, WHAT
CAN YOU SHARE ABOUT TO YOUR
LOVELY TIME WITH THEM?
>> YOU KNOW, THEY WERE CHASING.
A FAR FIELD WANDERING INTERVIEW,
SPOKE THE TRUTH TO THEM AND
CAN'T TELL YOU DETAILS.
LOOKING FORWARD TO DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE 25TH AMENDMENT AND
DISCUSSIONS I NEVER SERIOUSLY
UNDERTOOK WITH ANY OF MY
COUNTERPARTS.
THEY WERE LOOKING TO BUILD A
STORY LINE AT THE CONCLUSION OF
WHICH WAS ALREADY WRITTEN.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT MIKE PENCE SAID UP IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT CRITICIZE AND BE
CAREFUL ABOUT CRITICIZING THE
FBI, BECAUSE THAT IS CRITICIZING
THE RANK-AND-FILE, I LIKE
MIKE PENCE VERY MUCH, AN OLD
FRIEND GOING BACK 20 PLUS YEARS,
BUT I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED BY
THAT, YOUR REACTION TO WHAT HE
SAID?
>> WE ALL FRIENDS, AND TWO FOLKS
WHO USED TO WORK ON MY
CONGRESSIONAL STAFF WHO ARE NOW
YOUNG KICK BUTT FBI AGENTS
ACROSS AMERICA, GOOD PEOPLE
HARDWORKING FOLKS THAT CARE
ABOUT AMERICA, BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
A POLITICIZE LEADERSHIP IN NK
LINE LOOKING AT THE JOB IN
HELPING THE SPOKESPERSON ON CNN,
WHEN YOU SEE THE FBI ENGAGE IN
THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY IT IS SO
DEEPLY TROUBLING.
ONE COULD EASILY, EASILY TAKE ON
THE FBI LEADERSHIP WITHOUT
ALIGNING IN ANY WAY THOSE FOLKS
THAT ARE OUT TRYING TO KEEP THE
STREETS SAFE AND KEEP US SAFE
FROM CRIME ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: WHAT WERE YOU DOING
THE NIGHT THAT LIZ CHENEY LOST
THE RACE IN WYOMING?
OR ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THAT IN
ANY WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM?
OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE FRIENDLY WITH
THE CHENEYS AS MANY OF US WERE,
BUT THAT IS THE END OF THE ERA,
IS IT NOT?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT IS.
IT'S FROM A TIME GONE BY, A
SENSE OF SHE SPENT HER ENTIRE
TIME REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE OF
WYOMING AND GOING AFTER A SINGLE